[Music]
it's seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast here are our top stories this
morning uk scientists say there's no
immediate need for a fourth covid jab as
the current booster gives older adults
strong protection
the booster is not only working but it's
working for a long period of time
downing street drinks fresh claims by
the prime minister's former advisor
dominic cummings of another garden
gathering during the first lockdown
a third day in detention for the world's
best tennis player as the blame game
continues over the handling of novak
djokovic's vaccine exemption
honestly i hope that he all gets sorted
as soon as possible like for the sport
we need him here it's that simple like
he's one of the most influential sports
people probably of all time
justice at last the family of the
murdered jogger ahmed arbury celebrates
as his three killers are sentenced to
life in prison
overcoming the odds the refugee children
determined to succeed in the classroom
after a challenging start to school
and the second century of the game for
australia's usman guaja as left
england's qriket is facing a massive job
to save the fourth ashes test in sydney
the weather wind and rain will spread
eastwards today with sunshine and
blustery showers following but tomorrow
looks drier and according to we'll take
a look at papers with the broadcaster
and author gemma forte and the editor of
spiked tom slater
[Music]
hello there a very good morning thanks
for being with us i'm jonathan samuels
and we start today with a positive
development in the fight against the
omicron wave sweeping across the country
uk scientists say covert booster jabs
provide 90 protection against
hospitalization in the over 65s for at
least three months and this means
there's no need for a fourth jab for
vulnerable people just yet but
protection for older adults who haven't
had a booster is much lower the uk
health security agency says it's
prioritizing rolling out first booster
doses to all age groups that's as the
pressure grows on hospitals facing both
the shortage of beds and staff shaman
freeman powell has our first report
in the last week of december 3.7 million
people in the uk were infected with
coronavirus
but while cases remain high they are not
as severe and the jcvi credits the
booster people aged 65 years and above
have over 90 protection against being
hospitalized and most importantly they
are protected for up to three months
from their booster dose so that's really
really good news the booster is not only
working but it's working for a long
period of time
while omicron causes milder symptoms
than previous variants the sheer number
of cases means hospitals are overwhelmed
and the medics we usually rely on to
look after us are barely coping i think
the fact that we've had to bring the
army
really demonstrates the huge pressures
that services are under at the moment
and my members will tell you that it
doesn't feel like it's stabilizing at
the moment
and at the moment they can't see
an end to it
hospital staff across the country are
exhausted and burnt out and now the
surge in omicron cases is creating
shortages with many staff off sick and
unable to work
but with almost 40 000 nhs staff off
sick because of kovid there are fears
that assistance from 1
800 armed forces won't be enough
as it stands the number of 1-1-1 calls
are on the rise
ambulances are waiting more than an hour
to hand over patients and a lack of
social care is preventing 10 000 people
from leaving hospital beds
but despite this some experts are
hopeful we don't know whether there will
be any further nasty newton strains
always uh variants uh are happening
whether any of those becomes worse for
the human race and particularly us here
in the uk remains to be seen but at the
moment we're certainly on the right path
for omicron and it looks to me as though
the health service will survive
there will be more tough times ahead but
there's optimism too
that the darkest days of the winter wave
may soon be behind us
shimon freeman powell sky news
well we can show you the latest covet
data now the united kingdom recorded 178
250 new covid cases as well as 229
deaths in the past 24-hour period
bringing the total number of deaths
within 28 days of a positive test to 149
744
well as we've been hearing this morning
ambulance workers are among those
feeling the pressure being put on the
nhs and i'm joined now by unison
national officer and former paramedic
alan lofthouse alan good to see you this
morning thanks for joining us nhs staff
still struggling with sickness and being
off with uh kovid how difficult has it
been for the ambulance service i mean
it's it's really people are struggling
at the moment you know i mean every year
we
report on winter pressures but this is a
winter like no other before
and i think one of the things that
that's really important is for people to
know that those ambulance staff out
there those that are taking the calls in
the control centers those that are
responding in ambulances are doing
everything they can but unfortunately
you know if they're told to self-isolate
they have to take themselves out which
means that there are fewer people out
there to answer the number of calls
they're coming in call numbers are up
and it really is you know it's
people are struggling to do the job they
love they know they're struggling to
have a break during their shift they're
struggling to finish on time the people
who taking the calls are absolutely
exhausted we've had reports that it's
never been like this before
yeah i mean the good news as we were
just hearing is that we seem to be
on the right path now with uh omicron
but there's still a long way to go
well absolutely and what we can't have a
situation where every winter we hit this
point and if there is a new variant we
have you know armies uh responding
instead of ambulances we've got you know
calls that people are struggling to get
to that you know we've got demoralized
staff we need a much more longer term
plan to have the right numbers of staff
in there so that we're not dipping into
these winter crisis points in such a
deep way
in the summer the government announced
this extra 55 million pounds to boost
staff numbers including 999 call
handlers um that must have had a a big
impact hasn't it the thing is with uh
money like that is it isn't recurring so
it doesn't you know the ambulance
services don't get it each year so they
tend to sort of you know be able to
throw it at you know trying to provide
private ambulances to to fill demand but
you've only got a limited number of
staff there you know these are great
jobs people love working in ambulance
services but
the pressures are so great at the moment
that what we really need is these
careers to be looked at these jobs to be
looked at to really attract people in
their long term so rather than throwing
55 million pounds at it you look at them
you know over a couple of years to try
and get more staff so that you have that
extra capacity in the system because you
know we've had 10 years of our ambulance
services in real terms being cut right
back so that you haven't got the number
of staff that used to be there so it's
been you know it's very difficult to
cope with these sudden surges in demand
so you see ambulance services announcing
major incidences and critical incidences
and i just don't think you should have
that as a long-term plan it really
doesn't reflect very well on the
government the the ambulance service the
employers and the staff themselves are
doing everything they can but they're
working in such difficult circumstances
we've heard these uh some nightmare
stories of uh certain parts of the
country uh where people are being
advised to get a relative to drive them
to hospital because it'll just take too
long for an ambulance to get them uh to
hospital cases where it might be a
suspected heart attack even or a stroke
is that still happening
well yeah and this is the sort of you
know the place that ambulance services
find themselves in is if they don't have
ambulances what do they tell the public
so our call handlers who who take you
know the phone calls from um the public
who then try and work out the number of
ambulances they've got to deploy to
those people really struggle and and so
what do you say to somebody you know a
lot of people will contact the ambulance
service who have chest pains not all of
them will be having heart attacks and
not all of them will end up you know
with their heart been stopped but it's
such a risky thing to do so you know
people are really put into a difficult
position and i guess there is something
that the public can do on this which is
to really use the 999 service sparingly
think about actually should i be calling
one one one instead and getting advice
can i look after myself can friends and
family come in and look after me instead
of relying on on the 999 service and
therefore you know when somebody really
is unwell there are there are ambulances
available for them but these you know
the people taking the calls are being
put into some really difficult positions
and i don't think it reflects on them i
think it reflects again onto the fact
that they've just been pushed into this
by a lack of long-term planning a lack
of funding for ambulance services that's
thrown us into this crisis and then on
top of that you have the new um omicron
a wave
yeah i mean you're accusing the
government um uh uh here of of the
crisis that that uh the service faces
but of course um it is omicron isn't it
it's the fact that it's so transmissible
that is causing so many people to be off
sick that's that's out of the
government's control
well yes i mean i i do accept that but
the fact that every winter we're in a
situation where ambulances are queuing
for six seven hours outside i'm outside
and ease with patients that they can't
offload because the social care system
isn't able to take patients out of
hospital the other end i mean these are
long-standing problems so the government
can't really say that this is all
omicron the unique thing that's
happening at the moment is instead of
running a a winter sickness level at
let's say five or six percent you know
ambulance services are trying to deal
with 16 to 17 sickness levels so yes
that is the new thing but it's on top of
a pretty um you know cutback service
that that is trying and struggling to
cope with
every year demand is up on ambulance
services every year this is you know
something that is predictable and
therefore the government should be
planning for it and i you know i think
that they aren't
okay well we're all uh extremely
grateful of course for the the work that
ambulance crews have done over the the
last couple of years and continue to do
let's hope the the darkest days are now
behind us uh alan lofthouse national
officer for health for unison thank you
thank you
oh well it might be a new year but the
allegations of sleaze surrounding the
prime minister continue boris johnson's
former advisor dominic cummings is now
claiming that another rule-breaking
party was held in the downing street
garden just a few days after staff were
pictured
enjoying cheese and wine skies chief
political correspondent john craig has
the latest
following the disclosure about lord
brownlow the tory donor lobbying the pm
for a pet project a great exhibition
well who should uh pop up but our old
friend westminster's favorite pantomime
villain dominic cummings here is a
14-page blog
under the headline parties photos
trolleys and variants and we're back to
the allegations about the partying in
downing street now there's good news and
bad news for the pm from mr cummings his
former aide 15th of may that's the one
that featured on the front page of the
guardian a few weeks ago and has aroused
all sorts of controversy there's the
photo 15th of may was no party says mr
cummings but the bad news for the pm the
inquiry should look at the 20th of may
when there was another socially distant
drinks he claims so what mr cummings is
saying is that the person at the front
of the photo there is a civil servant
called martin reynolds and he was
sitting there with mr cummings he's in
the photo on the left the picture the
table at the front of the picture
there's the pm and carrie johnson there
mr cummings said i had several meetings
at that table that day and then he said
the pmi continued after uh the meetings
broke up someone brought a bottle of
wine out to the table it may have been
martin but i think it was the pm himself
who went inside he said he carried on
chatting about domestic priorities and
so on here comes the latest allegation
there was a social event on may the 20th
i and at least one other spad that's a
special adviser
said this seems to be against the rules
and should not happen we were ignored i
was ill and went home to bed early that
afternoon but i'm told this event
definitely happened what does all this
mean it means that sue gray she's the
civil servant investigating all these
party allegations it's almost certain
now to widen her inquiry to include not
just the 15th of may but this new
allegation about the 20th of may
john craig there okay let's head to
australia the world men's tennis number
one novak djokovic is nearing the end of
his third day in an australian
government detention hotel after being
denied entry into the country earlier
fellow tennis player and famously
outspoken aussie nick curios said
djokovic's absence at the upcoming open
would be bad for the sport and that he
thinks all the drama will have fired up
the defending champion
if he's allowed to play the australian
open
i don't want any bar of him i reckon
he's going to be off he's going to be
like
very determined to play well and stick
it to everyone of what's going on and i
don't want any bar of that novak
honestly i hope that he all gets sorted
as soon as possible like for the sport
we need him here it's that simple like
he's one of the most influential sports
people probably of all time
let's head to melbourne join sky news's
nicole johnston um nicole there are
protesters there are they for
or against the detention
well they're against the detention and
this detention is taking place right
behind me
in this hotel it's really a waiting game
for novak djokovic and his team now he's
about to have his third night in
detention it'll be four nights in total
until a court meets in melbourne on
monday to determine whether due process
was followed in the cancellation of his
visa in the meantime he has asked for
his personal chef
to be able to access him and provide
meals for him he's also asked to be
moved from this hotel to some
accommodation with a tennis court in
melbourne both of those requests have
been rejected at the same time he now
has some extra company inside this hotel
though i think it's probably unlikely
they're able to see each other a czech
player renata varachova has also had her
visa cancelled going to show what a
confusing mess this is turning into and
she's also in this hotel now as you said
there are protests continuing
a lot of anti-vaxxers have
joined the protest
as well as people from the melbourne
serbian community a couple of hundred of
people are there
it's quite quiet
but they're certainly vocal and they
have been turning out every single day
on the streets of melbourne though
there's not a lot of sympathy for the
situation of any tennis player who wants
to enter australia without a vaccination
and that's because melbourne enjoyed one
of the toughest lockdowns in the world
more than 206 days of lockdown in
australia now more than 90 of people are
vaccinated so it's a really strong
pro-vaccination uh situation here but
again it's very chaotic about how the
australian open is going to deal with
this with conflicting reports and leaked
messages coming from tennis australia in
the federal government with all sides
fighting and blaming each other
okay we'll learn more on monday nicole
thank you
having your own personal chef would be
nice wouldn't it
something to think about let's head to
the united states now where a father and
son have been sentenced to life in
prison without the possibility of parole
for the 2020 murder of black jogger
armored arbory a judge in the u.s state
of georgia also gave a life sentence to
their neighbor but ruled that he could
seek parole after 30 years in jail katie
barnfield
reports relief for the family of ahmad
arbury
hand in hand they walked down the
courtroom steps after his killers were
given life in prison i knew that today
would come
when
when it would come
i didn't know but i know today would
finally come amen
on the 23rd of february 2020 ahmad
arbury a black american had gone out for
a run in a predominantly white
neighborhood in the u.s state of georgia
and never came home
instead he was targeted by these three
men who have now been sentenced for his
murder
a judge said that mr aubry was pursued
in pickup trucks for five minutes before
being cornered and shot by father and
son greg and travis mcmichael and their
neighbor william bryan who claimed they
were attempting a citizen's arrest on a
suspected burglar he was killed
because individuals here in this
courtroom
took the law into their own hands
but the case has again raised questions
about racial justice in the southern
united states mr aubry's family lawyers
described the incident as a modern day
lynching and in response to the jury's
verdict in november president biden said
we must recommit ourselves to building a
future of unity and shared strength
where no one fears violence because of
the colour of their skin
the men waved their right to address the
court at the hearing but their lawyers
say they plan to appeal the convictions
katie barnfield sky news
also making news this morning 16 people
have died and 10 others have been
injured in an explosion as an office
cafeteria in southwest china it's
believed a gas leak caused the blast
a sky news investigation has revealed
that huge numbers of weapons including
firearms and knives have been seized in
courtrooms during the pandemic official
data shows that over a thousand knives
and blades have been confiscated in
crown courts since april 2020 it follows
concerns over the security of courtrooms
after the death of a man who managed to
sneak acid into a dock before swallowing
it
there's been some progress for people
fighting to get cladding laws changed
leaseholders living in buildings under
18 metres high will no longer have to
pay for potentially flammable cladding
to be removed from the outside of their
homes a letter seen by sky news from the
treasury to the housing secretary
michael gove suggests that the secretary
of state will be able to threaten
developers with taxation or what's been
described as legal solutions to ensure
they pay up
new research suggests asylum seeking
children who are separated from their
parents are on average more than three
years behind other pupils by the time
they take their gcses but a school in
north london is working to break down
the barriers holding back refugee
children in the classroom aisha zahid
has been to meet some of the pupils and
the staff offering them supports
these teenagers all have very different
stories to share about how they arrived
in the uk
but a determination to succeed is
something they all have in common after
facing challenging starts at school
i hope to live with eights and nines and
wish to get into the university and
study to be a neurosurgeon
it's difficult when you can't talk it
takes time
and it's it's about the future
because
i would like to study business
i don't know anything about
english about language
about the rules at school it's so thin
difficult
when i come to the
school
i know everything i know the rules and
the language it is
i feel is good
very important
you study
if you study like you get better better
you whatever you want you do
the first part you focus your study you
don't go there someday another way
between them they've made treacherous
journeys to flee dangerous situations in
their home countries staff here are
working hard to ensure they're supported
beyond the classroom
our main
barriers that we're trying to overcome
are isolation vulnerability to
organize crime or gangs in the area
being able to make sure that they're not
at high risk of any self-harm and just
making sure that there's no abuse in the
families so we try and have after-school
activities that help with english with
socialization making friends just making
sure that their moods and their mental
health are being looked after data
suggests
resettled refugee and asylum seeking
children are around a year and a half
behind their peers entertainment
the gap widens to more than three years
for those who arrived in the uk
separated from their parents
unaccompanied children are also more
likely to face exclusion
teachers say there needs to be a shift
in focus
attainment often is just a measure of
what a young person arrives with they
tend to leave with something not
dissimilar progress is a real measure of
a journey that a young person makes from
from start to finish so you get the
literacy rights you get the curriculum
right we found that with our refugee
children the progress is phenomenal
the pupils here continue to thrive and
it's hoped there will be plenty more
success stories as schools like this one
work hard to break down the barriers
that can so often stand in the way for
refugee children
aisha zahid sky news
hello again such sad news wasn't it
yesterday to hear about the uh the death
of sir sidney poitier and there have
been plenty more tributes from hollywood
and beyond he was of course the first
black man to win a best actor oscar for
his performance in lilly's of the field
he died at the age of 94 after the most
incredible career well joining me now is
the founder of the british urban film
festival emmanuel aniam sigwe uh great
to see you thanks for being with us um
he was quite remarkable wasn't he um how
have you been reflecting on his life
over the last 24
well hours morning jonathan um it's very
surreal to be talking about the sydney
party because
i'm actually writing a book about uh
prolific black figures in film and
television
and
understandably sydney's name came up
because not only was he a prolific actor
and literally winning everything um that
was there
he was also a very prolific film
director
um now i've not met the man and
i wish i did but i know someone who has
and that would be rain tryout who's the
daughter of richard pryor
and when i talk about his um
achievements as a director he was the
first black director
to gross a movie over a hundred million
dollars and that was stir crazy which
starred richard pryor and gene wilder in
1980 and that's a record that stood for
nearly 40 years until he was surpassed
by ryan cooper's black panther
and that's just one example of so many
prolific firsts that sydney partier
achieved and like i said i wish i was
on set with him i was i wish i was in a
room with him i just wish i was on a
protest or civil rights march with him
he he was that guy he was everywhere he
was
the foundation for everything that's
come since
yeah you mentioned civil rights there
and of course he was a regular wasn't he
on the big screen at the time of racial
segregation in the in the us what impact
did he have
well i'm sure
many of uh your viewers have heard
stories about him on protest with harry
belafonte and
what people may not know is what he
gained on those marches i know he
provided money from his own pocket as
did harry and many others to support
um
civil rights leaders entertainment being
provided for obviously the famous march
from summer to montgomery in 1964 just
little things like that and if we could
all kind of
find it within ourselves to kind of give
back and be humble about
you know the the bigger struggles and
the bigger battles uh that are out there
in the world and that's still out there
in the world today then i think we could
learn
a whole lot from sydney project and i'm
sure many people
have
heeded his approach to life
and of course away from film he did a
great deal of work in the bahamas where
where he grew up he was a real
humanitarian as well
he was indeed yes he was the ambassador
to japan um for 10 years um and not many
people know that he actually sat on the
board of disney for eight years so this
is a man that wasn't just transcending
film race relations civil rights
politics but business as well and like i
said many people have
since sydney procte gone down that route
of doing more
across so many fields i mean in america
just recently um the great football icon
from madden pass and he was very
prolific in not just commentating but as
a coach and as a player and as a video
game and sydney forte in film is that
and many more you know there are
acronyms such as vip
mvp goats go 80
sydney party was all of those things and
so much more and i'm so glad that he was
around enough
around long enough should i say to
see if his flower's been given to you
yeah well said uh they're making a
broadway play about his life there'll be
a lot to cram in uh to that stage
production great chatting to you
emmanuel aniyam asigwe thank you so much
thanks jonathan
hello again this saturday morning nice
to have you with us we're going to take
a look at the papers now the broadcaster
and author of gemma forte and the editor
of spiked tom slater nice to see you
both again gemma let's kick things off
shall we with the the ft
um i mean once covid is less of a a
pressing issue the cost of living crisis
is really going to bite and of course
the government is is running out of time
when it comes to how how to deal with
this
they are and i think these are the
stories that are going to be dominating
sadly in 2022 as things are going to be
getting very difficult for a lot of
people financially so of course keeping
the triple lock on pensions was a 2019
election pledge and promise however soon
at wanting to reel back on that a bit so
whilst it protects
state pensions which are um collected by
12 million people many of whom will be
conservative voters
it does rely on looking at wage growth
and also inflation now wages have grown
considerably up to eight percent so it
would mean that the state pension went
up quite considerably if sunac sticks to
that pledge um but that said it's only
going to go up to about sort of ten
thousand pounds a year or around that
figure i don't have the precise yes
that's it ten thousand a year
now ten thousand pounds a year whichever
way you look at it isn't a great deal to
survive on when you think that the cost
of food is going up um and fuel fuel
right and prices are going to be soaring
when it comes to the elderly this is
such a huge deal because of course many
will have to make that choice between
whether they can eat whether they can
put the the the heating on so i have a
feeling that this is going to cause a
real storm and he's probably going to
have to roll back on it that isn't a
good look when a lot of mps recently
have decided to do something and then
done a u-turn so we'll see how this pans
out but i really think the the elderly
have suffered so much in the last couple
of years you know it is up to these
politicians they are caretakers if you
like of people they have to address this
fuel crisis really really urgently
um i know the wholesale price of gas
isn't their fault but it's something
that needs addressing right away and i
wonder you know boris johnson at pmq's
the other day he made a really bad slip
talking about um how people get 140
pounds a week off their bills uh for
fuel relief they get 140 pounds a year
and you see it worries me when when
people in positions of power have
so little idea of of money in terms of
sort of what ordinary people consider a
lot of money or a little it it concerns
me greatly and sue nak's wife of course
is worth 430 million
so i just hope they look after our
elderly and make sure that they don't
freeze to death yeah it's gonna be a
real crunch point isn't it in uh in the
spring especially when that energy price
cap uh changes uh take place um tom
let's uh talk about the
story that is in the telegraph at
dominic cummings he dropped another
dossier didn't he yesterday what did we
learn
yes another one of his kind of
interminable blog posts has landed this
one alleging that on the 20th of may
2020 there was a socially distanced
drinks party in the downing street
garden this was five days after that now
kind of infamous wine and cheese get
together in the garden which was
splashed across the front page of the
guardian and which dominic commons was
actually in attendance at interestingly
mr cummings is saying that the one on
the 15th that he was at was completely
legit but the one on the 20th that he
wasn't at was wrong and he warned
against it so i guess viewers will make
up their own mind about this but it is
just this kind of never-ending story
about rule breaking in number 10 or
alleged rule-breaking shall we say
i tend to have kind of two conflicting
feelings about it on the one hand there
is the hypocrisy there is the sense that
you're seeing you know number 10 being
shown to have you know had parties last
christmas at a time when students were
being fined 10 000 pounds for having
house parties that sense of uh one rule
for them one rule for everyone else but
i can't be the only one who feels like
these stories becoming increasingly
marginal on the level of rule breaking
that's being alleged they were outside
and all the rest of it and i also think
it's quite interesting that cummings
thinks he has any kind of moral
authority on the questions of the rules
and when i want when they have been bent
or broken given a lot of people still
haven't forgiven him for the whole
barlow castle to bottle so yes this
story continues to run and run but i
can't be the only one who feels like the
wheels are falling off just a little bit
okay interesting uh interesting points
uh let's move on to the guardian uh
gemma we've been discussing this all
morning the very sad passing of sydney
poitiers what a towering figure he was
absolutely and you have had some really
amazing tributes on sky this morning um
so i won't add much other than to say
that he was an exquisite actor in things
such as guess who's coming to dinner in
the heat of the night of course he was
the first black actor to receive an
oscar in 1964. he was incredibly
handsome but it's also of course every
time we mention sydney pottier we
mentioned the fact that he was black
because he was a huge trailblazer to be
cast in a film in anything other than
you know at the time
and as he said himself every portrayal
of a black person on screen at the time
was negative buffoons clowns shuffling
butlers really misfits and that then he
came along and he decided i will not be
stereotyped so he tried to pick his
roles as carefully as he could and
there's a fantastic quote where from one
of his films he said it wasn't about
marrying a white woman on screen it's
more about slapping a racist white man
on camera and you just have to look at
the history of the time to understand
how monumental moments like this
were and where he began hopefully we
reach a point where black actors aren't
always mentioned you know the color of
their skin as as he had to be at that
time what a man yeah what a man indeed
all done with such grace and uh and
charm um tom some good news for once
about uh kovid and coronavirus uh the
daily mail saying that omicron patients
are 90 percent
less likely to be hospitalized compared
with previous waves um providing they've
been boosted
yes exactly so what we're seeing here is
just the effect of the omicron variant
being somewhat milder but also
importantly just these boosters have
really been incredibly effective in
terms of pushing down on hospitalization
and death we've seen the health
secretary say that in this current wave
it's now guaranteed it is worse that
this will not cause a surge in deaths
and this is a huge change of tuning we
should remember because in the week
before christmas of course we had sage
modelers suggesting and projecting that
potentially we could soon hit 6 000
deaths a day you know it's currently
somewhere between 1 and 200 has been the
sort of average so it really really is
good news it shows that really what a
lot of the south african medics were
saying when omicron first arrived that
it was milder that they were seeing mild
cases that the vaccines were holding up
and the boosters were particularly
effective all of that has really been
borne out and whilst the pressure there
is pressure on the nhs at the moment it
does feel like all the signs are very
positive
not just for the kind of next couple of
weeks but the sense that we'll have to
go back into restrictions anytime soon
whatsoever so yes very good news in the
mail today yeah let's hope so i've been
an optimist throughout the whole uh
chronovirus uh crisis and it's not
really done me much good but let's hope
your optimism tom um uh uh uh will carry
us through i'm sure it will um now let's
talk about um
exercise uh gemma um the alzheimer's
society warning that um uh dementia is
is uh on the rise with the older
population but there are ways that we
can help combat it and keep our brains
healthy
yeah and i would say that this is
another positive story researchers in
california have found that exercise
keeps the brain young so we know that it
keeps the body sort of trim and the
muscles strong etc etc but there's a
class of proteins that enhance
connections between brain cells and when
you exercise these get firing and they
can help stave off dementia they're
saying 150 minutes a week can help stave
off cognitive decline um i love being
active i love exercise i hate diet so
this is good news for me and if it
encourages people to get out for a walk
and keep going and keep going into their
old age i think this is really good
positive news to hear because you know
it doesn't have to mean killing yourself
in the gym it just can be a really good
fast walk as well and i'm already at the
stage where i go up sometimes upstairs
and can't remember why so i probably
need to maybe do a bit more
excellent and tom you've got 20 seconds
to tell us about this unicorn
yes um so scientists are stepping out of
this asian unicorn which is a name for a
very elusive animal which lives in laos
and vietnam it's numbers believed to
have been plunging even potentially
below 100 so rare that no biologist has
ever actually seen it in person so
concerns that this very rare and
fascinating species might die out if
we're not careful
good stuff tom gemma great to see you
both we'll speak again in half an hour